For the first inequality, I have x is less than 3. If you have trouble
remembering the less than symbol, remember that the arrow points to the left, or
to numbers less than zero. I know I need a parenthesis because I can't be equal
to. So, it must be the number line 2 or number line 4. I want numbers lower than
3, because x is less than 3, so it must be 4. For the interval notation, I want
numbers that are from negative infinity all the way up to 3. So, that must be b.
For x greater than or equal to 3, I want to use a bracket, that's number line 1.
The interval notation would be d because I get d equal to 3 and then have any
number bigger or up to positive infinity.
Here, I have 3 is greater than or equal to x. I'm used to seeing the variable on
the left side, so I'm going to flip this in equality around. I need to make sure
that the arrow still points to the x when I switch this inequality around. I
want 3 to be greater than or equal to x, and I want x to be less than or equal
to 3. For the number line, it must be at number 3. I need a bracket at 3 and my
values could be less than or equal to 3. The interval notation would be a. I
could have numbers from negative infinity all the way up, and equal to 3. This
must mean that the last one is 2c. I want numbers greater than 3. Here are
numbers greater than 3 and here are numbers between 3 and positive infinity.